ja herzlich willkommen die festtage sind
vorbei die zeit die man gerne mit seinen
liebsten verbringt leider aber sind alle
anderen auch dabei zum beispiel die
verwandten mit denen man sich jedes jahr
streitet über gott die welt und die
politik heute möchte ich erfahren wie
wir mit andersdenkenden ein gutes
gespräch führen können und warum die
zukunft unserer demokratie davon abhängt
meine gäste sind die schauspielerin
autorin und publizistin laura de weck
und die philosophin und argumentation
trainerin romy aster herzlich willkommen
in beiden danke ja wann haben sie denn
das letzte mal mit jemandem diskutiert
der politisch ganz anderer meinung war
sie ich ja bei mir war das bei einer
meiner letzten lesung da gab es einen
älteren herrn der wartete bis alles
fertig war und kam dann auf mich zu und
war sehr aufgebracht weil ich während
der lesung werbung gemacht habe für den
vaterschaftsurlaub weil in der schweiz
ist es ebenso es gibt kein elternurlaub
also nach der geburt eines kindes darf
nur die mutter urlaub nehmen und nicht
der vater und der hat mich sehr
angegriffen und er war auch sehr also
frauenfeindlich fast frauenverachtend
könnte man sagen und ich habe aber
versucht bis zum schluss obwohl ich mich
sehr angegriffen fühlt möglich zu
bleiben
ihm zuzuhören und ganz am schluss war er
dann sagte er fast vorwurfsvoll auch das
wird aber komisch sie dankt schlacht
aber sie sind am lidrand lachte man kein
schlechter mensch und ich glaube das hat
eher erwartet er wollte in den streit
rein und ganz überrascht wie nah kann
sie überrascht dass aber ich musste mich
auch ehrlicherweise wirklich an den
riemen reißen
höflich zu bleiben ja ok aber die über
diese trennung zwischen person und
meinung werden wir noch sprechen das
klappt ich ganz wichtigen wann haben sie
das letzte mal mit ihrem gesprochen mit
dem sie überhaupt nicht auf einer linie
waren
überhaupt nicht auf einer linie ist
schon eine weile her nicht auf einer
linie ganz kurz vor dieser sendung ich
habe mich mit ein paar philosophen
kollegen darüber unterhalten wie wieviel
bünemann rechten im diskurs geben sollte
tatsächlich und das war schon kontrovers
obwohl viele suchen ja nicht unbedingt
dazu neigen stark politisch position zu
beziehen die denk mir immer sehr lange
über alles nach insofern war das jetzt
kein extrem harte defense der da
irgendwie verhandelt wurde
ja also irgendwie die situation zeigt
das passiert gar nicht so oft dass man
mit jemandem räder der politisch ganz
anders denkt aus als wir selbst und die
frage ist warum sollten wir das
überhaupt tun warum sollten wir mit
menschen reden die ganz anders denken na
ja also ich glaube man sollte mit
andersdenkenden reden um andere
positionen kennenzulernen um seinen
eigenen tellerrand zu überwinden
ich glaube es gibt gibt unterschiedliche
ziele die man in so einer diskussion
verfolgen kann also eins scheint mir zu
sein
die gegenseite überzeugen zu wollen
beispielsweise weil man in der
demokratie lebt und es darum geht
irgendwelche mehrheiten zu generieren
also am ende hat man etwas erreicht wenn
möglichst viele leute so denken die man
selbst weil die dann in wahlen so
abstimmen wie man sich das selber
wünschen für die beispielsweise das ist
ja erstmal eine gute sache ein anderes
ziel kann aber auch sein jemand anderen
besser zu verstehen beispielsweise also
so wie dieser herr mit dem sie
gesprochen haben also womöglich hat ja
ihren standpunkt am ende etwas besser
verstanden
sie seien vielleicht auch jetzt sagen
wie gut er war
der war ein sex ist oder ein frauenfeind
sogar da stößt man schnell an seine
grenzen
das verstehen wollen sagen wir mal aber
womöglich hat der ihren standpunkt sie
etwas besser verstanden und eine andere
sache ist und das finde ich jetzt viel
zu häufig unterschlagen eigentlich oder
das ist eigentlich das eleganteste
diskussion stil zu sein nämlich sein
eigenes überzeugungs system überprüft zu
wollen also mal zu schauen wie gut
begründet sind eigentlich meine
positionen so und weil wir unseren
eigenen denkfehler gegenüber viel viel
blinder sind als den denkfehler ein
anderer leute gegenüber hilft es dafür
andere leute einzuspannen damit die
einen sagen was an der eigenen position
eigentlich nicht stimmt und dafür ist
eine diskussion gut scheint mir und erst
dann spürt man wie schlecht begründet
auch die eigene position ist zumindest
geht mir das oft auf so was ist für sie
das primäre motiv und mit anderen ins
gespräch zu kommen
ja ich bin sicher dass wenn man nicht
miteinander redet dann isoliert man sich
ja und ich glaube dass es gefährlich
wenn verschiedene gruppen sich einzeln
isolieren und isolation ist gerade im
moment sehr im trend und auch
insbesondere bei staaten die waren sie
immer mehr isolieren isolieren und das
halte ich für hochgefährlich und ich
habe die erfahrung immer gemacht jetzt
vielleicht auch eben mit diesem älteren
mann wenn man sich öffnet sich selbst
öffnet und es schafft die gegenseite
auch ein spalt weit zu öffnen dann dann
kann der dialog entstehen und macht die
erfahrung eben auch wenn ich als autorin
heftig kritisiert werde zum beispiel
leserbriefen dass ich da sehr beleidigt
werde sobald man sich politisch äußert
kriegt man der leserbriefe und was sie
kriegen wir unsere heftige drohungen
muss genau morddrohungen oder
vergewaltigungs wünsche oder so die
kommen meistens per post und sind
meistens anonym da kann ich nicht drauf
antworten aber sonst bin ich immer jeden
leserbrief beantworten das habe ich mir
vorgenommen weil ich einfach auch gute
erfahrungen damit gemacht hat absurd
ja ich schreibe dann immer ebenso
höflich wie möglich zurück bedanke mich
dass ich meine texte so intensiv
lesen und und schließe und gehe auch auf
die auf den inhalt ein und und was man
dann zurückbekommt ist wirklich
erstaunlich also die leute entschuldigen
sich meistens dass sie so beleidigend
waren sie freundlich richtig man mehr in
den zahlen sie freuen sich dass man
ihnen geantwortet hat oder gut manchmal
wird man dann noch heftiger beleidigt
und sie sehen sich bestätigt das ist
alles ins heimische was ich da sagen so
und dann dann macht der dialog
tatsächlich keinen sinn mehr
bei dem punkt kann man dann den dialog
auch abbrechen aber sie machen immer das
dialogangebot selbst wenn ich sehr
beleidigt werde er sie haben es erwähnt
dialog kann auch ein mittel sein um die
wahrheit zu finden um eigene schwächen
der eigenen position zu entdecken und
wenn man ganz zurück geht in die
philosophie geschichte zu platte und
dann findet man genau dieses motiv auch
da weiter hatte dialoge geschrieben und
geklärt dass man im gespräch auf die
wahrheit kommt das gespräch zu erkennen
dies führt das denken letztlich auch
nichts anderes ist als ein
selbstgespräch
sehen sie das ähnlich sehe das genauso
also ich glaube je besser man darin wird
mit anderen gründe auszutauschen desto
besser wird man darin überhaupt gründe
zu verarbeiten gewissermaßen also das
ist einfach das beste übungsfeld dafür
ja gerade aus denken zu lernen scheint
mir und insofern finde ich den den
diskurs mit andersdenkenden
so nützlich eigentlich um so eine
fundamentale fähigkeit zu erwerben oder
zu verbessern und da kann man glaube ich
sehr viel gewinnen
ich habe gelesen dass sie ihre
schulaufsätze damals schon aus dialoge
geschrieben haben ja ich hatte tolle
deutsche das erlaubt denken sie
eigentlich in gesprächen die ganze zeit
meine eric kolumnistin der wundervoll
diese eben tages anzeiger
veröffentlichen und und sich hieraus
buch aus zehn ische dialoge geschrieben
zwischen ganz unterschiedlichen parteien
ja ich kann nichts anderes ich geb's zu
ich kann keinen gebundenen texte
schreibe
ich denke nicht so in dialogen aber ich
liebe dialoge und ich glaube an den
dialog darüber werden wir eben heute
vermehrt sprechen warum und ich dialog
ich interessant finde dann schreibe ich
mir auf und ich glaube ich mag den
dialog deswegen so gerne weil dialog
immer was mit beziehungen zu tun hat und
beziehung ist emotional und
emotionalität ist etwas was jeder sofort
versteht und das ist so ein bisschen das
ziel auch mit diesen dialogischen
kolumnen dass man sagt okay hier oben
bei der regierung werden irgendwelche
gesetze verabschiedet und die
bevölkerung entscheidet sich an der urne
für gesetze aber was hat es eigentlich
mit uns und unseren beziehungen unseren
emotionen zu tun
und das kann man eben dialogen sehr gut
abbilden ja bei ihm ist auch immer
dieses wechselspiel von politischen
öffentlichen dann hin zum privaten zum
dialog gelernt und wie sich bestimmte
politischen entscheide manifestieren
dann auch in ganz privaten leben ja eben
wie sie sagten bei platon irgendwie das
ist dass man eine erkenntnis hat das ist
ja ich glaube ich nehme an dass
psychologen so arbeiten dass sie den
patienten so viele fragen stellen bis
der sagt ah ich habe jetzt eine
erkenntnis über milch und die ist
heilend und manchmal wünschte ich eben
im staat und bevölkerung könnten auch
gemeinsam sich so befragen dass sie
gemeinsam zu der erkenntnis kommen
wir müssen besser dialog führen jetzt
diagnostizieren aber viele experten
einen verfall dieser diskussionskultur
die öffentlichkeit sei fragmentiert
gespalten polarisiert und der ton der
werde immer rauer und trauer
die debatten so scheint es sind härter
geworden im ton die öffentliche
auseinandersetzung polarisierte
schriller
dass der andere auch recht haben könnte
scheint keine option zu sein
so ziehen wir uns mehr und mehr zurück
gesprächsverweigerung ausgrenzung statt
dialog in den sogenannten echo kammern
der sozialen medien treffen wir
vorwiegend auf gleichgesinnte werden in
unserer welt sicht bestätigt richtig rau
wird der ton wenn im anonymen netz
jemand eine abweichende meinung vertritt
der andersdenkende wird zum feind haben
wir verlernt miteinander zu sprechen und
was bedeutet das für unsere demokratie
marias da haben wir verlernt miteinander
zu reden
ja das sagt man so ne also ich habe
meine zweifel dass wir jemals geld zu
reden also ich bin mir nicht so sicher
ob die zustände jetzt wirklich so viel
schlimmer sind als als vorher ich glaube
es wird medial sehr stark inszeniert
also wer mir jetzt da gesehen wie in den
medien streitsituationen dargestellt
werden und inszeniert werden wir haben
alle schon politische talkshows gesehen
nehme ich an
und da ist natürlich die die diskussion
immer inszeniert als ein als ein clash
und als was ganz kriegerisches camp
gewissermaßen und es gibt natürlich
jetzt die sozialen medien wo standpunkte
viel ersichtlicher werden also auch
standpunkte von ganz anderen spektrum
des meinungsspektrums und ich vermute
dass früher die leute tatsächlich
weniger ehrlich gesagt
aufeinandergetroffen sind mit ihren
unterschiedlichen meinungen entwickeln
als heute ja es ist ja auch irgendwie
lustig also einerseits wird immer davon
gesprochen dass es diese echo kann man
oder beziehungsweise in den sozialen
netzwerken ein filter blasen gibt lassen
sich auch mit gleichgesinnten sich unter
her genau das wäre so abgeschirmt werden
von den algorithmen der sozialen medien
von andersdenkenden
gleichzeitig wird moniert dass sich im
netz so unmöglich gestritten wird das
sind ja zwei beobachtungen die erst mal
gar nicht zusammenpassen
also wenn wir tatsächlich so abgeschirmt
sind von andersdenkenden
dann ist es ja statt
nicht dass da so harte konflikte zutage
treten
ich habe auch meine zweifel ob wir da
eigentlich so abgeschirmt sind man
könnte sagen die konflikte werden
seltener aber heftiger wenn sie dann
auftreten
durch diese anonymität vielleicht ja ich
glaube gar nicht dass die anonymität
eine rolle spielt leider gibt es auch
regierungschef die überhaupt nicht
anonym sind und auch so so hart und
aggressiv äußern wie anonyme in den
chats aber ich glaube es geht um den
effekt wie kann man am effektivsten
miteinander reden das ist gerade den
wettbewerb den ich beobachte und eben
als theatermacherin fällt einem
natürlich auf dass sie dass die leute
wirklich schön da in die handwerks kiste
greifen der der professionellen erzähler
im theater und im drehbuch dass sie
wirklich so mit spannungs dramaturgie
arbeiten dass sie sagen wir müssen die
leute genauso wie im film wird etwas
erwartet und wir müssen diese erwartung
durch wendepunkte brechen
und ich glaube dass wir eigentlich in
einem demokratischen diskurs ja auch so
erwartungen haben
wie verläuft ein demokratischer diskurs
dass wir höflich miteinander
sensibilisiert dass wir gewisse
überzeugung haben gemeinsame
überzeugungen wie menschenrechte
pressefreiheit das recht auf opposition
und so weiter und plötzlich kommen da
welche und sagen die pressefreiheit
finden bin ich richtig also wir glauben
die medien die lügen und natürlich hat
man dadurch eine extreme spannung wenn
den zuschauern erzeugt diese spannung
ist auch noch unterhaltsam und als
drittes kommt noch dazu
was man eben auch was auch im mittel ist
was in schlechten kriminalfilmen oft
verwendet wird die die regeln brechen
wirken sympathisch also im krimi es
meistens in wien kommissar seinem dienst
nicht trinken darf und aber weil seine
frau ihn verlassen hat oder weil der
fall so schlimm ist dann greift er doch
zum alkohol und das macht ihn menschlich
und man denkt auch er befreit sich aus
diesen fesseln und genau das gleiche
passiert eben auch wenn wenn jemand sagt
auch diese ganzen menschenrechte die
brauchen wir noch alle ich auch wir
befreien uns jetzt aus diesen fesseln
und wir wir sind jetzt mal wir selber ja
und damit haben sie einfach wahnsinnig
viel erreicht mit diesen mitteln ist es
große aufmerksamkeit großes
entertainment
auch wenn man jetzt gesehen hat in dem
film mit den politikern die aufeinander
einschlagen also das ist ja wirklich
filmisch das ist ja wie aus einem
theaterstück und genau und sie wirken
auch nur sympathisch dabei das bessere
theater ist dass wir eben und das ist
eben die theatermacher und die autoren
die müssen jetzt nachkommen und die
müssen sich jetzt auch politisieren um
dagegenzuhalten
eine sache dazu sagen also ich finde das
sehr interessant und ich glaube da ist
auch viel dran ich glaube trotzdem dass
die anonymität also zumindest so im
diskurs unter privatleuten in den
sozialen netzwerken schon eine gewisse
rolle spielt also jemanden wie sie weiß
ja dass er als ich wie ich eben höhere
dass auch leute unter angabe ihres
namens furchtbare dinge einen kopf
werfen also außerhalb der anonymität
dennoch glaube ich dass anonymität in
dem sinne dass man sich halt nicht
gegenüber steht etwas ausmacht also gar
nicht anonymität im sinne von niemand
kann herausfinden dass ich das war der
enns das gesagt hat sondern anonymität
in dem sinne
ich muss mich nicht mit der person als
mensch konfrontieren hier sondern und
ich werde auch überhaupt nicht ich kann
die person auch gar nicht als mensch
wahrnehmen sondern ich sehe in
irgendeiner kommentarspalte eine
position die mir meiner irgendwie
diametral gegenübersteht und die ich
nicht mag und dass diese position ja zu
einem menschen gehört mit dem ich
vielleicht einige gemeinsamkeiten habe
der mir vielleicht ganz sympathisch wäre
so wie sie auf den bei diesem alten
herren oder älteren herren sympathisch
waren das kann man ja in dem moment
überhaupt gar nicht erreichen und ich
glaube dass diese situation eine ist
dies begünstigt das leute also dass das
niveau des diskurses sehr tief sinkt ja
stimmt eigentlich das ist so ähnlich wie
die die eingewanderten die von denen ich
immer höre dass sie diesen satz nicht
mehr hören können ja dich mag ich ja
aber der rest das ist das ist mir zu das
ist also eine masse
die die gefallen ist und warum sagt er
dich dich mag ich weil er mit ihm
gesprochen hat oder weil er mit ihm in
den dialog gegangen ist und dadurch ja
was erfahren hat was er vielleicht von
dem gegenüber gar nie gedacht hätte also
eine ähnliche erfahrung haben auch
personen gemacht die an dieser aktion
mitgemacht haben diesen deutschland
gehabt deutschland spricht
initiiert von zeit online in der schweiz
ist dass die schweiz spricht zum ersten
mal im letzten oktober wurde das
durchgeführt wo anders denken die
politisch anders denken auf einander
getroffen sind
jetzt ist natürlich die frage diejenigen
die sich der anmelden und das freiwillig
machen die haben schon eine bestimmte
offenheit
die frage ist wie holt man die anderen
hast du eine idee
also ich glaube es ist dieses jahr etwas
besser gelungen tatsächlich leute da
rein zu holen die sehr sehr
entgegengesetzte standpunkte haben also
da haben wir verschiedene medien dieses
jahr tatsächlich mitgemacht und ich
glaube dadurch war die spannbreite der
position schon recht gut aber klar die
leute haben eine gewisse offenheit
gegenüber so einer diskurs situation und
irgendwie wollen vielleicht die andere
person kennenlernen andererseits ich
weiß es nicht vielleicht haben wir ja
auch leute mitgemacht weil die einfach
ein starkes sendungsbewusstsein haben
und gar nichts von dem gegenüber lernen
wollen aber dann in dem gespräch
feststellen dass es jedoch in einer
weise bewegt hat von der sie nicht
gedacht hätten dass es sie bewegt also
im nachgang dieser aktion bei so events
von deutschland spricht habe ich
mitbekommen es gab diesen
einen polizisten der gegen die
gleichgeschlechtliche ehe also die er
unter gleichgeschlechtlichen menschen
war und in seinem gespräch auf jemanden
getroffen ist auch eine frau die in
einer gleichgeschlechtlichen
partnerschaft lebt und der hat hinterher
gesagt er sei so tief berührt gewesen
davon dass er in diesem gespräch so eine
fundamentale einsicht hatte nämlich dass
das was er sagt jemand anderen verletzt
dass das nicht einfach nur irgendeine
position ist mit der er durch die welt
läuft sondern dass das etwas ist das
wenn es ausgesprochen wird das potenzial
hat jemanden zu verletzen und den hat
das wohl so wie er selber auf diesen
events glaube ich war ja mal gesagt hat
sehr bewegt und vielleicht verändert
auch ein stück weit und unerwarteter
weise eben
es ist schon interessant es gibt also
jetzt kommen wir wieder auf diese auf
dieses zusammenspiel zwischen personen
und und meinung und dass die andere ist
nicht nur ein meinungsträger sonst eine
person mit einem leben das haben wir
gesehen aber auch dass wir die beiden
dinge trennen sollten dass jemand hat
eine abwegige eine andere meinung haben
kann trotzdem als mensch ganz nett sein
kann es gibt dieses buch hier mit
rechten reden ein leitfaden und die
autoren stellen bestimmte regeln auf wie
man eigentlich mit andersdenkenden
sprechen sollte und das erste die erste
regel leitet unterscheidet person und
rede
und ich fand das erstmal ein leuchten
und musste dann aber irgendwie denke das
ist ja einfach schwierig also wie kann
jemand aus mensch so abstoßend seien
aber dass die umgekehrt so die
abstoßende meilen vertreten und trotzdem
aus mensch irgendwie angenehm sein und
wenn man dann mit dem spricht geht man
nicht als verräter für andere die von
außen zuschauen ich finde das ganz
schwierig wie gehen sie damit um
hatte ich es ganz ganz schwierig also
ich weiß nur dass der verein netz
courage zum beispiel ganz gute
erfahrungen damit macht das die
sozusagen menschen die erleben oder die
autos stark
beleidigt er verletzt und beleidigt
wurden im internet dass man sich da
melden kann
und dann kommen opfer und täter zusammen
und reden und meistens ist es genau so
wie bei mir und den leserbriefen
das ist nicht zu einer zu einem prozess
gerichtsprozess kommen muss das niemand
niemanden angeklagt und im gespräch man
merkt aber okay das ist ja auch ein
mensch gegenüber der hat ja vielleicht
genauso ähnliche probleme wie ich und
man dann zusammen kommt aber das stimmt
das macht man das macht man nicht macht
man nicht sofort
und es gibt noch ein anderes büchlein
das kürzlich erschienen ist zivilisiert
streiten von marie luisa freak und sie
nimmt eine unterscheidung wieder auf der
belgischen politikwissenschaftlerin
schon der anruf die zwischen einem feind
und einem gegner unterscheidet und ich
fand das ganze interessant weil ein
feind ist der ganze mensch involviert
beim gegen nur die meinung also ich
glaube dass es nun also dieser dieser
tipp oder diese dieser hinweis dass man
zumindest versuchen sollte also es geht
ja immer in erster linie darum das zu
versuchen und es gar nicht zu versuchen
nur weil man zweifel hat dass einem das
gelingt ist vielleicht gar nicht so klug
sondern den versuch zu unternehmen die
person von der meinung zu trennen oder
von dem standpunkt das scheint mir
erstmal ein sehr guter hinweise zu sein
und ich glaube ich würde sogar noch
weiter gehen und sagen ich würde auch
die einzelnen meinungen die leute so
vertreten voneinander versuchen zu
trennen
denn was man ja sehr häufig sieht in der
in dem umgang mit personen die
berufsmäßig unter anderem furchtbare
sachen sagen sarrazin zum beispiel aus
meiner sicht dass dieser ungarn einer
ist der nicht unbedingt dadurch geleitet
ist dass man sich jetzt mit einzelnen
positionen dieser person
auseinandersetzt sondern die person wird
quasi mit dem bündel mit dem gesamten
bündel von behauptungen die sie so in
die welt gesetzt hat identifiziert und
aus dem diskurs ausgeschlossen und
ich glaube dass es besser wäre sowohl
die person von diesem bündel von
meinungen zu trennen als auch die
meinungen innerhalb des bündels von
einander zu separieren und sich
anzuschauen welche davon sind also
wirklich indiskutabel
also können nicht oder sollten nicht
diskutiert werden weil da in der rote
linie überschritten ist und welche sind
womöglich falsch aber diskutabel
und mit diesen positionen scheint mir
kann man sich dann sehr wohl auseinander
setzen im öffentlichen diskurs und das
würde dem diskurs auch eine ganz andere
form geben also eine die weniger von
empörung und und schreierei geprägt ist
mehr von einer sachlichen
auseinandersetzung mit meinetwegen
falschen und vielleicht sogar
unangenehmen positionen das sind schon
mal wichtige grundregeln gibt's weiter
ich frage sie meinen die argumentation
in einem forum für streit was sind für
sie die drei bis vier wichtigsten regeln
ja also tatsächlich glaube ich es gibt
drei regeln die man sich aneignen könnte
es gibt vielleicht noch andere ansätze
aber unser ansatz ist jedenfalls ein
dreischritt der darin besteht zunächst
mal zu wiederholen was das gegenüber
überhaubt gesagt hat also oft kommt er
mir seinen redeschwall entgegen und da
stecken irgendwelche argumente drin oder
irgendwelche behauptungen aber da kommt
auch noch ganz viel anderer kram und
womöglich ist das nicht so besonders
aufgeräumt also nicht nur aus bestimmten
politischen spektren sondern überhaupt
wenn man diskutiert das ist ja ganz
normal und dann einfach zu sagen okay
also wenn ich das richtig sehe ist ein
punkt der der und greift sich etwas raus
was dann in die diskussion ein sehr
aktiver mal genau also man vermeidet
missverständnisse man zwingt sich selbst
dazu auch gut zuzuhören na das ist ja
auch etwas was man irgendwie sich
aneignen muss und wenn man das geschafft
hat dann im zweiten schritt und das ist
sehr contra intuitiv weil natürlich beim
streiten ja vor allem kritik geübt aber
im zweiten schritt dann gemeinsamkeiten
herauszustellen zwischen den positionen
also zu sagen das und das sehe ich auch
so
also dass
das an deiner position das finde ich
plausibel überzeugend interessant
wichtiger punkt hier sind wir einig und
dann in einem dritten schritt ernst
tatsächlich die kritik an diesem
standpunkt üben und dadurch hat man sehr
aufgeräumten diskurs und man greift sich
einen punkt raus sagt worin der was
daran gut ist und sagt dann was daran
schlecht ist und dann hat es geschafft
irgendwie schon mal eine diskussion gut
aufzugleisen und ich würde tatsächlich
empfehlen das in einer diskussion so oft
wie möglich zu machen also wenn man das
wort ergreift zu versuchen diese
schritte zu durchlaufen so lange man
noch übt und dann irgendwann geht davon
fleisch und blut über ich höre so
interessiert weil weil bei diesen ganzen
streitgesprächen und sowie denke ich
gerade die die menschen glaube ich mit
denen ich gerade am allermeisten streite
sind meine eigenen kinder
da sucht man ja auch immer nach regeln
wie kommt man denn jetzt also ich meine
kinder sind in diesen kreml alter wo
auch nur so gebrüllt wird
nennen wir sie also auch scherz gut
bürger oder sowas
wir kommen wie kommt es an sie ran und
ich hatte auch das gefühl dass man
ebenso parallelen macht wie kommt man
denn sonst irgendwie an menschen die wir
gerade nur schreien und und ich hatte
eben als erste strategie hatte ich das
was vielleicht auch so gesellschaftlich
passiert ist zu sagen man muss die
ängste und sorgen wahrnehmen dass man
sich geht und sagt oh gott was ist denn
mit dir los und warum schreist du denn
so und kann ich denn irgendwas für dich
tun und dann merkt man ganz schnell das
bringt überhaupt nichts weil das kind
ist zwar vielleicht schnell still aber
kaum hat man sich umgedreht brüllt es
wieder los weil es kapiert hat wenn ich
schreie bekomme ich aufmerksamkeit
ich glaube das ist eben auch so oft
passiert dieses dieses dieses schreien
honorieren und dann wählt man natürlich
eine andere strategie und das ist die
empörung zu sagen du kannst du jetzt
nicht so mit mir reden und ich bin deine
mutter und du kannst mich doch nicht so
anschreien und dann passiert das was
jetzt passiert es schreien nur auf beide
seiten und beide seiten sind empört
empörung empörung führung und wie kommt
man da wieder raus und sozusagen also
den ersten aspekt fand ich da schon den
werde ich sicher das ist halt auch
anwenden zu sagen okay was also
man muss sich die argumente des anderen
erstmal rauspicken und ja ich hatte als
allerletzte lösung sozusagen zu sagen
ja so kann man nicht reden
wir müssen wenn wir miteinander reden
wollen dann müssen wir leise sein und
beleidigend sein und so findet man dann
auch plötzlich heraus warum das kind
schreit oder warum der wutbürger
schreibt ja die sagen dann
erstaunlicherweise ja dann plötzlich
auch ich bin ich ich will auch auf dem
schoß sitzen aber das geschwisterkind
sitzt auf dem schoß oder die sagen ich
will ein gummibärchen und dann weiß man
ja sehr klar und sehr genau welche sorge
man jetzt ernst nehmen muss das
gummibärchen sicher nicht also das heißt
diskutieren debattieren will auch
gelernt sein von kindesbeinen an
wie war das bei ihnen zu hause wenn ich
fragen darf welche diskussionskultur
herrschte da wir haben sie diskutieren
gelernt also ich habe mit meiner mama
zusammen gewohnt und wir haben uns immer
richtig gefetzt meine mutter erzählt
dass ich mit zwei jahren so ganz also
gut genug sprechen konnte um ihr verbal
kontra zu geben und von da an war das
auch mein modus offenbar ich glaube
schon dass ich da viel gelernt habe über
über das streiten und darüber wie das
man sich dass man sich einen standpunkt
bildet und dass man sich in der sache
versucht es muss durchzusetzen
das zivilisiert zu tun haben wir dann
später gelernt meine mutter konnte das
wahrscheinlich schon vorher aber diesen
modus gemeinsam gefunden stellte dialog
was gebracht er ist ja inzwischen stadt
sehr friedlich das bei ihm haben sie
sich auch gefetzt zu hause aus sehr
wenig sehr wenig ich glaube wir sind
alle harmonie wichtig in der familie
aber
ich bin vielleicht sagen wir es mal so
schweizerisch aufgewachsen durch den
sogenannten indirekten dialog der in
direkte dialog ist etwas was ich für die
theaterstücke sehr sehr oft benutze ich
mag das aber es ist fürs echte leben was
nicht unbedingt tun
naja eben das typisch weitere man hat
eine figur die möchte gerne etwas sagen
aber sie traut sich nicht weil sie zu
ängstlich ist oder höflich bleiben
möchte oder den konflikt scheut und
deswegen nimmt sie einen großen umweg
und und und und und hofft dass der
andere dann schon irgendwie spülen wird
was was was sie denn meint und für
theaterstück ist das wunderbar weil der
konflikt immer größer wird und nie
ausgesprochen wird und immer weiter und
größer und größer
vorangetrieben wird aber ich lebe jetzt
seit zehn jahren in deutschland und wird
im deutschen natürlich auch viel gelernt
die dinge direkt auszusprechen und sie
sagen aber die schweizerinnen und
schweizer können eines besser nämlich
besser über sich selbst lachen
vielleicht kann sie weniger gute seiten
ab zumindest gelesen aber der humor ist
ja ein thema also der reaktoren hier
sagen regel nummer 10 ist es glaube ich
ein streit ohne lachen ist kein streit
ja oder nein denn es ist krieg
dann ist es krieg also glaube ich auch
ich glaube dass das lachen oder das
lernt man ja auch auf der
schauspielschule lachen ist also ganz
nah beim wein
das ist das dass es das zwerchfell wird
gelockert und man macht sich aufmachte
ich aufhören gegenüber und nach also man
hört auch immer wieder so die regel als
schauspielerin nicht auf der bühne
weinen oder lachen weil die figur ist
dadurch erlöst wenn jemand es schafft zu
weinen oder zu lachen dann heißt das ich
akzeptiere ich akzeptiere die welt wie
sie um mich ist ich akzeptiere den
konflikt also sie
sie ist wirklich offen und bereit für
den dialog und im theater sucht man
immer das gegenteil wir sind sollen ja
so möglichst lange im konflikt stecken
die figuren also es heißt lachen tag
mache ich mich auf und bin
gesprächsbereit
und das ist ein super natürlich ein
super mittel
ich beherrsche das nicht gut also das
humorvolle streiten also mit sehr
vertrauten leuten schon also ich meine
jetzt auch nicht streiten im sinne von
man setzt sich über irgendetwas wer
jetzt als nächstes oder den müll
runterbringt oder so sein wenn ich meine
auch in der sache zu streiten also über
irgendein thema zu streiten und das
humorvoll zu tun ist nicht meine stärke
muss ich ehrlich sagen ich glaube dass
das quasi dass es ganz toll ist wenn man
das hinkriegt ich glaube aber schon und
da würde ich mit denen nicht
übereinstimmen ich glaube nicht dass es
sonst kein streit ist also ich glaube
man kann ganz ernst und ganz
konzentriert und in der sache ganz
unnachgiebig miteinander diskutieren und
streiten ohne das wohlwollen füreinander
zu verlieren also in großer achtung des
gegenübers sehr ernst streiten
das scheint mir kein problem zu sein ich
glaube also das klingt für mich selbst
plausibel aber die rolle des humors ist
glaube ich so wie es verstehe auch diese
distanz die man hat zu der eigenen
meinung und das problem scheint mir zu
sein dass diese distanz heute oft wird
man identifiziert sich so stark mit
seinen überzeugung und wenn man die
verlieren würde
moralische überzeugung dann fühlt sich
das so an als würde man an treffen sich
selbst verlieren und so in eine
diskussion zu gehen ist wahrscheinlich
nicht optimal
ja weil es vielleicht was gar nicht mehr
mit also wir wissen gar nicht mehr was
wir meinen sondern wir glauben was wir
meinen es ist zu einer glaubensfrage
geworden glaube ich glaube ich bin ein
religiöser glaube ist so stark so ja
also wenn top sagt
die new york times liegt und die new
york times sagt schromm blüht dann wem
soll ich glaube es steht aussage gegen
aussage und ich glaube schon die new
york times hat die viel glaubwürdigeren
argumente dass sie nicht lügen und dass
ihre arbeiten recherchiert sind und so
weiter und trotzdem kann es ja da auch
sozusagen zum glaubenskrieg kommen
welcher glaube stimmt jetzt und davon
glauben abzukommen das würde ja
tatsächlich bedeuten weil die fronten so
verhärtet sind sich ja irgendwie eine
form von identifikation zu verlieren ich
glaube schon dass es das ist eine gute
idee ist sich nicht mit seinen meinungen
zu identifizieren also ich glaube es ist
eine gute idee sich mit einer bestimmten
haltung zu identifizieren die darin
besteht dass man eben versucht nach
besten möglichkeiten zu wahren
überzeugungen zu kommen und alles
aufnimmt was einem zur verfügung steht
um dieses ziel zu erreichen also
beispielsweise auch die argumente
anderer leute und wenn man sich mit
dieser haltung identifiziert dann kann
es ja sehr gut sein dass man eben also
dann folgt es eigentlich daraus dass man
jederzeit bereit ist seinen standpunkt
zu überdenken aufzugeben anzupassen und
diese diese starke identifikation mit
meinungen steht einen da ja eigentlich
im weg also höher man erstmal mit einer
bestimmten meinung identifiziert ist
dann kann es ja eigentlich also dann
kann einem noch so ein gutes argument
jemand bringen und noch so einen guten
grund nennen und man wird an seiner
meinung fest halten müssen weil man
sonst gar nicht mehr klar kommt also
deswegen würde ich sagen sollte man sich
dringend fand verabschieden weil das
heißt sie sagen die vorbedingungen dafür
dass man sich überhaupt überzeugen
lassen von guten argumenten ist eine
solche haltung und sonst sind argumente
weil ich für die katz ja also ich
argument runs auf jeden fall sehr schwer
also es gibt so ein paar psychologische
effekte die die da immer wieder genannt
werden also es gibt den sogenannten bag
feiern
effekt der darin bestehen soll
dass menschen die mit gegen evidenz
konfrontiert sind also mit gründen die
gegen ihre meinung sprechen dass bei
diesen menschen sich die ursprüngliche
meinung er noch verhärtet als als denn
irgendwie schwächer wird und dass es in
der forschung ziemlich umstritten ob es
das gibt also das geld eine ganze zeit
lang mal so als text book fall aber das
ist gar nicht mehr so klar ob das
wirklich in der weise existiert aber was
auf jeden fall nachgewiesen werden kann
ist der sogenannte confirmation bayers
also den effekt dass menschen evidenz
unterschiedlich bewerten je nachdem wie
gut die zu ihrem ursprünglichen
überzeugungs system passt also wenn ich
schon eine feste position habe religiöse
überzeugungen politische moralische
überzeugungen aber auch ganz ganz banale
dinge und ich bin mit evidenz
konfrontiert die das in abrede stellt
oder in zweifel zieht dann bewerte ich
diese evidenz als weniger einschlägig
als weniger wichtig man kann nachweisen
dass man sich schlechter erinnert an
solche evidenzen dann sendet das aus und
selbst wenn es mal kurz an einen run
gekommen ist dann schlüpft es einem ganz
schnell wieder weg und das sorgt dafür
dass leute dazu neigen und zwar alle
menschen also das ist jetzt auch das ist
etwas dem wir alle ausgeliefert sind
alle dazu neigen nach bestätigung die
ganze zeit für ihre positionen zu suchen
aber nicht nach etwas was die eigene
position falsifizieren könnte und da
kann man mit einem training in
analytischen denken und mit mit dem
expliziten versuch gegen evidenzen zu
suchen also auch wieder eine haltung die
man sich aneignet schon sehr viel
ausrichten
der vix iconia ich erst aus dem
schauspiel laufs auf der bühne aus der
fiktion
ich möchte dass ein bisschen
gegenüberstellen auch die rolle von
argumenten von guten gründen und danach
tiroler von geschichten die man erzählen
emotionen von von bildern die etwas
auslösen
ja also ich habe auch den gleichen
eindruck also die zahlen die die zahlen
sich nicht mehr aus wir sehen das
irgendwie in der klimapolitik
es könnte noch mehr wissenschaftler
kommen noch mehr beweise liefern dass
wir jetzt sofort handeln müssen um gegen
die klimaerwärmung was zu tun aber das
zählt nicht mehr sondern die erzählungen
zählen jetzt und und und die die
politiker werden so profi erzählern und
erzählen gute geschichten die glaubhaft
sind und wie ich vorhin gesagt habe ich
glaube es ist jetzt an der zeit hat eben
auch die profi erzähler die die autoren
die filmemacher die schauspieler und so
weiter aktiv werden und wiederum auch
fiktionale geschichten erzählen um ihre
eigene politische erzählung zu machen
und was ich toll finde ist dass es
gerade sieht man das überall also in der
schweiz auf jeden fall also in den
letzten vier jahren seit der
masseneinwanderung initiative ist das
explodiert das bei jeder volksabstimmung
gibt es jetzt schauspieler die
irgendwelche performance machen es gibt
musiker die die lieder rappen zum
abstimmungs thema es gibt filmemacher
die kleine clips machen und so also die
die ganze ganzen erzählt profis haben
sich jetzt sehr politisiert überhaupt
ist einfach unglaublich wie sehr sich
diese zivilgesellschaft politisiert
hatte nicht in den letzten jahren und in
der direkten demokratie ist das ein
bisschen noch besser erkenntlich und mit
viel erfolg
also mit viel erfolg
wenn man so die letzten vier jahre
betrachtet konnten da konnte mit viel
erzählungen mit viel aufklärung gegen
die chancen rechtspopulistischen
erzählungen an der aufklärung heißt
jetzt nicht nüchterne argumente sondern
geschichten über emotionalität das meine
ich mit der emotionalität und genau das
werden was sonst das mittel eher von
populisten ist ich meine es gibt von
ludwig wittgenstein einen schönen satz
zu dieser rolle von gründen der sagt am
ende der gründe steht die überredung das
heißt doch irgendwie letztlich führten
kommen wir mit gründen nicht sehr weit
am schluss sehen dass andere dinge
entwickeln gefühl sie aus
philosophischer schon eine richtige
kontroverse kriegen wir da nicht hin
also ich würde das überhaupt nicht in
abrede stellen wollen und ich finde das
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir ganz dass wir
auch geschichten haben und auch bilder
und gefühle und dass das alles in den in
den politischen diskurs insofern eingang
findet als man menschen die sich in den
diskurs einbringen anmerken kann dass
ihnen das was bedeutet und ich glaube
dass also das ist ja auch so eine
gängige diagnose dafür warum es mit der
sozialdemokratie und und mit links
progressiven strömungen so ein bisschen
hapert in der erreichbarkeit der der so
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen weil da
eben so ein kühler sagt owen die ganze
zeit herrscht und die die rechten
konserviert also rechts konservativ
rechten gruppierungen haben eben genau
diesen dieses tool für sich entdeckt und
und arbeit liegen dass wir jetzt nicht
in deutschland nicht so besonders
präsent sichtbar
und ich glaube aber dass es dass es
wichtig ist dass man die dinge die einem
wichtig sind tatsächlich auch mit werft
irgendwie vertritt und da hilft es
glaube ich auch wegzukommen von diesem
ganzen empörung modus und sich wirklich
zu fragen was steht hier eigentlich auf
dem spiel
worum geht's hier eigentlich und was sie
betrifft mich das und wie betrifft das
andere die mir wichtig sind und mit
diesem impetus dann in diskussionen zu
gehen gleichzeitig glaube ich dass es
fatal wäre jetzt nur noch auf das zu
setzen das haben sie jetzt auch gar
nicht vorgeschlagen
deswegen sage ich ich weiß nicht ob wir
da eine echte kontroverse haben obwohl
es wäre super wenn wir jetzt ein echter
kontroverser also lag laut klassische
dramen
wenn wir jetzt einen großen konflikt
hätten dann hätten wir noch sagen okay
dann hätten wir auf jeden fall
garantiert ist die zuschauer dran
bleiben hier weil wir eine spannung
erzeugt hätten weil wir die die nerven
der zuschauer gekitzelt hätten und weil
die dran bleiben wollen um zu wissen wer
geht als sieger aus diesem
streitgespräch raus und und dann
brauchen wir noch ein wendepunkt aber
das sonst kann jemand das studio
verlassen und dann hätten wenig
aufmerksamkeit also ich meine der streit
ist das eine die polarisierung aber der
kompromiss das ist ja auch was schönes
irgendwie was man wahrscheinlich lernen
muss wenn man politiker aber dort
politikerin ist weil man gemeinsam
handle und entscheidungen treffen muss
und ich würde da die frage interessieren
ob menschen die in einer direkten
demokratie leben die zusagen gemeinsam
handeln müssen und sich beschäftigen
müssen mit den vorlagen abstimmen ob man
da kompromissbereiter wird aus wenn man
eigentlich gar nicht miteinander handeln
muss oder sich nicht so empfindet die
hand natürlich man man akzeptiert den
politischen entscheid vielmehr also mann
also wenn man mit dem politischen
entscheiden nicht glücklich ist hat man
ja dieses tolle werkzeug man kann eine
initiative gründen und man muss nicht
das bundeshaus anzünden oder so das
heißt man man wird weniger aggressiv
also die schweiz kennt tatsächlich passt
keine politische gewalt das ist in
österreich anders das ist in deutschland
ganz anders
also ich glaube dass dieses gefühl teil
des politischen dialogs zu sein ist
extrem gewalt hindern und und überhaupt
ich bin sowieso ein großer fan der
direkten demokratie weil es auch extrem
bildet weil das die leute im dialog
behält also wenn man jetzt zum beispiel
über menschenrechte spricht nächste
abstimmung über menschenrechte das
hatten wir es letztes jahr das eine
ganze nation familienhaushalte unter
arbeitspartner das ganze nation über
menschenrechte spricht und sich eine
meinung macht und das beschließt das ist
einfach hoch bilden und das und was ich
auch toll finde ist dass man auch immer
ein abbild hat der gesellschaft also man
erschrickt nicht wie in deutschland
nachdem jahren und extrem hoch da sind
ja lauter rassisten aber da sind ja
lauter menschen die denken so wie wir
das gar nicht gedacht haben und man weiß
relativ immer genau das was die
gesellschaft gerade denkt ja ich bin
sind sie geben dem arzt in deutschland
politisch ungebildete das vermag ich
nicht zu sagen ich denke da müsste man
jetzt tatsächlich
politikwissenschaftlerin fragen da
spreche ich außerhalb meiner expertise
aber ich finde dieses die die idee zu
finden ist dass man menschen zutraut
gründe basiert gute entscheidungen zu
treffen die finde ich zumindest schon
mal sehr sehr gut und man kann da ja
auch so ein bisschen von förderungen
durch forderung sprechen also
man etwas wenn einem etwas abverlangt
wird dann muss man das halt so lange
einen üben bis man darin gut ist und
wenn so ein politisches system einfach
darauf gebaut ist dass man dass jeder
und jede imstande ist sich gründe
basiert also nach abwägung der der das
für und wider eine meinung zu bilden
über eine politisch zu entscheidende
frage und dann tatsächlich einfluss
nimmt auf das was passiert dann
überträgt das so viel verantwortung auf
die einzelnen bürgerinnen und bürger
dass ich davon ausgehen würde also es
würde mich überraschen wenn sich das
nicht niederschlagen würde
in einer höheren fähigkeit dann nach
einer weile auch somit gründen umzugehen
und politische entscheidungen also zu
treffen denn man hat sagt geübt so ja
und ich meine wir haben ganz am anfang
der sendung über dieses verstehen
gesprochen über das zuhören und dachte
das muss man üben
das ist eine kunst und der deutsche
psychologe friedemann schulz von thun
hat ja ein berühmtes modell entwickelt
des verstehens und einen vier ebenen
modell und wir sehen dass hier ganz gut
aus es gibt eine sachebene da kann man
eigentlich als zuhörer sich fragen was
sagt mir die andere person dann gibt es
eine selbst kundgabe ebene da hört man
da einfach ist offenbart die andere
person über sich dann was will sie
eigentlich von mir die appel seite und
dann die frage wie steht ihr andere
person zu mir ist ganz komplexes
geschehen und das damals schnell die
ebenen verwechselt werden können das hat
glaube ich keiner so gut gezeigt wie der
humorist loriot und wir hören uns ganz
kurz ein schönes stück gehört ja das ei
ist hart
das ei ist hart ich habe es gehört wie
lange hat das einen gekocht so viel eier
sind gar nicht gesund ich meine wie
lange dieses ei gekocht hat du willst es
doch immer viereinhalb minuten haben das
weiß ich was fragst du denn dann weil
dieses einigt viereinhalb minuten
gekocht haben kann
ich koche es aber jeden morgen
viereinhalb minuten
wieso ist es dann mal zu hart und
manchen weiß ich ich weiß es nicht ich
bin kein huhn und woher weisst du man
das ei gut ist ich nehme es nach
viereinhalb minuten heraus mein gott
nach der uhr oder wie nach gefühl eine
hausfrau hat das im gefühl im gefühl was
hast du im gefühl ich habe es im gefühl
denn das eiweiß ist aber es ist hart
vielleicht stimmt da mit deinem gefühl
was nicht mit meinem gefühl stimmt was
nicht ich stehe den ganzen tag in der
küche machen die wäsche bringe deine
sachen in ordnung mache die wohnung
gemütlich ich habe ich den kindern und
du sagst mit meinem gefühl stimmt was
nicht wenn ein ei nach gefühl kocht dann
kocht es eben nur zufällig genau
viereinhalb minuten
es kann jedoch ganz egal sein ob das
hochwertig viereinhalb minuten kocht
hauptsache es kocht viereinhalb minuten
ich hätte nur gerne ein weiches ei und
nicht ein zufällig weiches ei
es ist mir egal wie lange es kocht das
ist ihr egal es ist also egal ob ich
viereinhalb minuten in der küche schufte
mein name aber es ist nicht egal
das muss nämlich viereinhalb minuten
kochen das hab ich doch gesagt aber eben
hast du doch gesagt es ist
egal ich hätte nur gern ein weiches ei
gott was interner primitiv
[Musik]
ich bringe sie um bomben bringen sie ja
herrlich ein klassiker aber er zeigt
sich durch sehr schön das irgendwie an
dialog immer auch ausdruck einer
beziehung die sks ist läuft also er hat
es ja auf der sachebene wollte mit ihr
reden und sie redet alles auf der
beziehungsebene ich bin doch ein huhn
und so und jesus egal wenn ich in der
küche stehe und ich und ich verstehe
sehr gut und und es ist ja nicht so dass
nur menschen in einer beziehung sind
sondern eben auch die bevölkerung ist ja
auch in einer beziehung mit der
regierung die regierung ist eine
beziehung mit dem parlament das
parlament ist eine beziehung mit den
gerichten und so weiter demokratie ist
ja nur ein beziehungs spiel und und
damit diese beziehung so gut wie möglich
funktionieren braucht es ganz ganz viel
dialog bei dem pärchen jetzt schalke
nicht funktioniert weil sie aber zwei
verschiedenen ebenen waren dahinter
sorgt vielleicht hilft ja unser dialog
gar nicht leicht ist manchmal doch doch
[Gelächter]
auch bei einem liebespaar ist es braucht
ganz wenig um zusammenzukommen um sich
zu verlieben aber es braucht ganz viel
dialog um zusammen zu bleiben und ich
glaube auch es braucht ganz viel dialog
dass wir friedlich auf dieser welt leben
können also ich bin wie gesagt schweigen
da kommen wir wieder dieses diesen in
direkten dialog der nicht ausspricht
vielleicht das handeln noch besser als
als dialo visieren also wenn jetzt mal
in der sich seine selber kocht man kann
noch lange reden ich bin super toller
film ist aber man muss die spülmaschine
oder das ei
großes jahr für für dialog china politik
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe und
demokratie basiert auf dialogen es geht
wirklich nicht anders
und sie sagen da auch das nicht nur den
dialog zwischen zwei parteien sondern
möglichst viele stimmen sollen
involviert sagt ja und es darf niemand
ausgeschlossen werden deswegen liebe ich
die direkte demokratie so aber sie
schließt natürlich trotzdem leute aus
nämlich die einwanderer die ja auch von
diesen entscheiden
betroffen sind und da finde ich muss die
demokratie auch weiter geben man muss
wirklich alle ein schließen niemanden
ausschließen ich glaube der ausschluss
führt ganz schnell zu aggressiven denken
das heißt man sie aus der perspektive
der medien allen eine stimme geben und
als die frage ist der oft wien lädt man
einen talkshows wie weit geht man zum
zum rand hin
na ja also ich finde diese diskussion so
ein bisschen die hängt so ein bisschen
den gegebenheiten nach weil wir sind
halt nicht mehr in einer zeit in der wir
ein paar leitmedien haben und ansonsten
und wer da nicht auftaucht er hat keine
stimme sondern wir sind ja schon längst
in einer zeit in der sich die leute ihre
eigenen kanäle suchen die wir versuchen
vom öffentlichen öffentlichen diskurs
also dem diskurs der in den leitmedien
stattfindet auszuschließen und wir haben
ja gesehen dass das nicht dazu führt
dass die leute dann einfach denken ach
dann ist das wahrscheinlich doch nicht
so überzeugend dass wir uns da denkt man
denken ist ja ich denke eben an
so kann man in den sozialen medien die
sich dann aus bilden also gruppen
innerhalb der der sozialen medien aber
auch organe wie breitbarth oder so also
diesen amerikanisches online medium wo
halt ganz klar positionen unter die
leute gebracht werden die in klassischen
leitmedien ist schwer hätten also eben
auch falsch halten zum beispiel genutzt
werden um dort zu senden und mir scheint
dass die frage eigentlich sein müsste
wie bezieht man diese position in den
öffentlichen diskurs ein nicht tut man
es überhaupt oder das heißt klassische
medien sorgen auch
verschwörungstheoretiker einladen die
frage ist aber wie man mit denen
diskutiert das habe ich nicht gesagt ich
bin nicht sicher dass man die einladen
sollte ich glaube man sollte die
positionen die schon im öffentlichen
diskurs sind wieder nicht als bündel
betrachten sondern aber wenn du zum
öffentlichen diskurs gehört dann sind
die da dann die dort ist genau die frage
soll man jetzt ins fernsehen einladen
also in der talkshow deswegen ein land
das da bin ich mir halt nicht so sicher
ob das die einzige art sich ist sich mit
denen auseinanderzusetzen mit diesen
positionen
es gibt ja auch die möglichkeit über
diese über die position zu schreiben
oder über die position zu berichten ohne
die vertreterinnen direkt einzuladen und
dann den da irgendwie eine bühne zu
geben und ich glaube dass wenn man so
wie ich ihm gesagt habe dieses bündel
von positionen von menschen oder von
parteien oder sowas aufbricht und einige
dieser positionen die diskutabel sind
auch tatsächlich diskutiert im
sogenannten öffentlichen diskurs dann
fährt man schon mal besser als in als
indem man dieses gesamte bündel als also
quasi tabuisiert genau
also das heißt nicht dass man die jetzt
in jeder talkshow setzen muss die leute
selbst wo ziehen sie die grenzen ja eben
auch also diddy diddy irgendwo
eingeladen werden die
die lade ich gerne ein um ins gespräch
sie mit in den politischen diskurs zu
nehmen aber werden auch im theater ganz
auf die diskussion weil viele von der ag
eingeladen wurden im theater auf putin
zu reden
da verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht warum
man sie einlädt das meinte ich eben
vorher mit dem kind also wenn die
kapieren
denn ich fühle wenn ich hätte wenn ich
schreie wenn ich brülle dann lade ich
alle ein
dann werden sie weiter pöbeln weiter
hätten weiter brüllen also und
eigentlich muss man genau das versuchen
also weil mit pöbelnden leuten da hat
man natürlich wenig interesse wirklich
das was diskutieren und da ist für mich
die grenze weil er in der
sonntagszeitung untersuchung wohlstand
rechtspolitiker werden sind in den
medien über präsent ich glaube
deutschland ist das nicht anders
warum dann noch zusätzlich es muss ja es
muss ein gleichgewicht geben und
bestimmte diskurs tugenden
würden sie sagen müssen eingehalten
werden hat bringen nach eingehen auf das
was andere sagen dialogbereit zu seinen
minimalen maße wahrscheinlich
wir sind schon fast am ende der zeit
mich würde interessieren wie gute
gespräche eigentlich enden und ob die
überhaupt ende aus ihrer sicht gute
gespräche enden also natürlich als
autorin muss man sagen entweder mit
einer torte oder mit einem dialogischen
der immer so aufgebaut
im 2 protagonist agonist zwei figuren
die haben einen konflikt es gibt einen
wendepunkt und beide kommen anders raus
als sie reingekommen ist also die
drehbuch theoretiker sind extrem streng
da wir müssen sagen wenn ich glücklich
in die szene reingehe die eine figur
muss traurig wieder rausgehen also auf
jeden fall verändert weil sonst macht es
keinen sinn dass man dramaturgisch
gesehen in die nächste szene kommt die
leute sind nicht offen jetzt könnte man
das direkt übertragen und sagen ein
guter dialog ist der wenn man mit einer
neuen erkenntnis wenn man anders
reingeht rausgeht alsmann reingegangen
ist ja ich finde das ist
sehr schönes sehr schönes bild also ich
glaube ein gutes gespräch endet so dass
man mit einer reihe von neuen fragen
raus geht also dass man rausgeht und
sich fragen stellt die man sich vorher
vielleicht nicht gestellt hat und mit
denen dann so ein bisschen rum läuft und
dann vielleicht sie ins nächste gespräch
trägt das scheint mir und das passt ja
genau dadurch dass man irgendwie als
veränderte hinterher ausgeht im sinne
von man hat eine gewisse distanz oder so
zu seinem eigenen überzeugung systemen
zu seinen eigenen positionen nur anja
dieses ziel haben wir erreicht
das scheint zu mir dass mir so viel
herzlicher der weg frei dass der für
dieses gespräch
vielen dank nach ihnen
vielen herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen
und fürs mitdenken und jetzt
gleichzeitig stellen schon eine kunst
einen eindrücklichen film über die
süditalienische stadt matera eine der
diesjährigen kulturhauptstädte europas
bleiben sie also dran und reden sie
miteinander
[Musik]
al